don't give me this thing I have a
difficult time with the time and I don't
have time for this now that you have
time you make the time they wanted me to
become a police officer and to marry a
girl by the name of Heidi and to have a
bunch of children and to run around like
the fun clap family in The Sound of
Music but that's not what I saw this was
the vision of my parents but not mine so
he looked at me he says ah I started
Agora you have an accent I cannot use
you ah he's an actor politician and
former bodybuilder he won the Mr
Universe contest at age 20 and went on
to win seven mr. Olympia titles he
gained worldwide fame as a Hollywood
action movie icon
he's Arnold Schwarzenegger and here's my
take I'm his top 10 rules for success
volume 2 rule number one is my personal
favorite and I'd love to know which one
you guys liked the best and as always
you're watching if you hear something
that really resonates with you please
leave in the comments below
quotes around it to other people can be
inspired as well and when you write it
down it's much more likely to stick with
you as well enjoy
Oh
when I used to do seminars on how to
become a champion I would always ask
people why do you want to be a champion
or what do you want to come why are you
training and they will guy will get up
and you would say well I want to train
because I think that if I get muscular
and you know I feel like I'm getting the
kind of definition and then maybe can
enter a bodybuilding competition does it
sit down as if you think this way you're
going to be a loser you're never going
to make it because there's no maybe you
got to get up and say I want to be a
champion and I do whatever it takes
amount of hours it takes to pose into
this that the visualization looking at
training footage looking at motivation
of boxes of reading dizzy whatever it
takes I would do that's the answer I
want to hear from you you can detect
right away those that are going to be
shaky and that will fall behind and they
will not go all the way and those to the
very hungry and dead hungry you have to
develop because you have to create a
goal for yourself whatever that may be a
short-term goal and a long-term goal and
you got to go after that if you do not
see and if you do not believe it who
else will experiencing pain in your
muscles and aching and just think Oh on
and go on and gone and just last 2 or 3
or 4 repetitions that's what makes
actually the muscle then grow and it
divides can one from a champion and one
from not being a champion if you can't
go through this pain period you make it
to be a champion if you can't go through
forget it and that's what most people
like is I'm just having the guts the
guts to go in and just say I go through
and I don't care what happens you know
it aches and if I fall down I have no
fear of fainting in a gym because I know
it could happen I threw up many times
while I was working out but it doesn't
matter because it's all worth it
everyone has a problem with time but
today is 24 hours and we sleep six now I
know there's some out there that say
overall I need eight
well I say to sleep a little faster
because the bottom line is we have six
hours of sleep 20 files are available so
if 18 hours now available to your work
your family your hobbies and also to
learn something new or to do something
new which could easily be that you want
to learn a new language or that you want
to read and as a new resolution I have
to read a book every week or you say I'm
going to go and reshape my body so
you're going to go and take this hour
out of your schedule and say I'm going
to train an hour every day so this is
for most people a huge challenge but it
is totally doable I can tell them
because the kind of things that I did
when I came to this country I mean I
went to school I was working on
construction I was working out my five
hours a day I was taking acting classes
from 8 o'clock at night to 12 midnight I
was doing all of those things I wanted
to make sure that out of the 24 hours of
the day that I don't waste one single
hour because hours were too precious and
so there just want to tell people don't
keep me this thing I have a difficult
time with the time and I don't have time
for this now that you have time you make
the time had this need of coming to
America I mean when I started learning
about America at the age of 10 admit
because geography lessons and learned
about America and about the until the
first photographs
I remember those photos in the textbook
but also and super 8 millimeter film
footage that they showed in the
classroom you know about the Golden Gate
Bridge in the Empire State Building and
that the six-lane highways north I said
what am i doing in Austria with this
little road I want to go over there in
order to be part of the big deal and so
I had to always this desire that felt
like that the only way I ever would get
the America because in those days it was
in common that you buy yourself a ticket
to no one could afford that so I had to
kind of accomplish something big
that takes me to America and then when I
read about this guy reg Park who won mr.
universe three times and then became a
star in Hercules movies and then was in
Italy filming and then in Hollywood
filming I felt that it could be the
ticket I should become Miss Universe I
should become kind of a second rich Park
of course no one really bought into that
my parents thought it was totally insane
and I remembered that I hung up pictures
above my bed you know the for
inspiration pictures of reg Park in this
posing trunks know that my mother was so
concerned she called the local doctor
and she hadn't underlies the wall
because she thought that there's
something terribly wrong that I have
naked man above my face and all my
buddies had women hanging above the bed
and so she was concerned about that and
didn't just I think that my parents
really thought that there was something
terribly wrong of being dead driven you
know because I would come home at
lunchtime and instead of having lunch
over to 200 sit-ups and they were
neither we'll go to the stadium and they
will be lifting weight I will come home
at 10 o'clock at night and there will be
continually lifting weight so it was
like one of this insanity in the
military I will continue lifting weights
the matter how the training was and how
tough the basic training was I would
always then lift weights afterwards and
as a tank driver would have on the side
of the tank in the toolbox I would have
my weights my barbells and dumbbells and
my exercise bench and everything there
in order to be at any given time if we
stopped driving the tank and maneuvers
at 2:00 in the morning I would be able
to pull out my weights and again lift
for two hours my weight so I was really
a fanatic about the whole thing but it's
the only way you really get where the
way I succeeded because I became the
gauge of 20 at the youngest mr. universe
in London in the history of bodybuilding
because the youngest before then was a
rich Park the guy was talking about with
the age of 24 that I became the youngest
between but it was because I was like so
serious about the whole thing
and it
at the age of twenty one after one my
second mr. universe title I got an
invitation from Joe Weider who was the
publisher of all the muscle magazines in
America and also the person that had the
biggest wheels of weight training
equipment and had food supplement
companies and orders and he brought me
the America and so there was I mean six
years after my dream started I was in
America I think it's the most important
thing that we have a very clear vision
of where we go a goal where do we go
because you can have the best ship in
the world you can have the best cruise
liner but if the captain does not know
where to go
that ship will drift around the world
and out there that sea and we never end
up anywhere and this is exactly the way
it is in real life if you don't have a
goal if you don't have a vision you just
drift around you're not going to be
happy this is why it is so important to
have that vision now I created that
vision in Austria because I grew up
after the Second World War
Austria right along with Germany lost
the Second World War
thank God and the problem was that
everyone was so depressed because they
lost the war that there was alcoholism
everywhere there was of course
depression there was a terrible economic
situation there was famine there was to
Batian and all those things and also it
was kind of a little place and narrow I
felt kind of I wanted to get out of
there I wanted to escape and I couldn't
see myself really to work there in to
stay there to work in the factory of the
work on the farm although even to follow
my father's footsteps and to become a
police officer I couldn't see that
either as a maverick that's what my
parents wanted me to do they wanted me
to become a police officer and to marry
a girl by the name of Heidi and to have
a bunch of children
and to run around like the fun clap
family in The Sound of Music
but that's not what I saw this was the
vision of my parents but not mine and
luckily one day in school I watched a
documentary about America and I found
myself I knew exactly that is where I
wanted to end up
I wanted to be in America we had an
early meeting with Dino De Laurentiis
that didn't go so well
well it was different because Dino De
Laurentiis at an office he wanted me to
be in dog savage and he wanted me to
play the villain in Doc Savage and I
walked in and I always kind of you know
have a mouse that sometimes goes a
little bit too fast and the I said
myself there it I walked into the office
and there's Oh Dino standing behind his
desk and it was his huge desk ornate
Gordon kind of like French looking or
Italian looking I don't know what but it
was gigantic it was one of those partner
desk right and Dino the only thing that
stood out was kind of his chest and his
head because he's a little guy Dean is a
really short guy so I looked in and I
walked in his office and I looked in as
his hi Tina
why does a little guy like you need such
a big desk and to clean of the
horrendous you never say you little
right because he saw himself as a giant
so he looked at me he says ah it's not
an Agora you have an accent I cannot use
you and and I said again stupidly
who was talking about having an accent I
mean listen to you ah are you a Nazi ah
you know if you walk to her she walked
away because as a German accent so if
that was the end of it so I left the
office and my agent came up to me
grabbed me really forceful with my arm
and she said to me says I have been an
agent for 15 years this meeting was
exactly one minute and 14 seconds it was
the shortest meeting they've ever had
you just everything up goddamn it it
took me a month to get in here so he was
mad at me also so anyways a desk but
that's how the relationship started with
Deena but then when he bought Conan he
came to Spain there we were shooting and
the third day of filming after so the
dailies the footage should be film he
came up the Menace a - party negra
you accountant ah
and he walked off and Emilia's came to
me the director says this is the
greatest compliment that you can ever
get he said you're Conan isn't that
greatness yeah guess so and from that
point on we created this really great
relationship and we did movies together
and raw deal and then red Sonia and
Conan the Destroyer and kind of appeared
and there he was became kind of like a
father figure he became character reg
Park that I had in a bodybuilding world
Joe Weider he became that character in a
movie world that I could go to for
anything who would give me advice who
always had wonderful compliments and
kind of took me in as part of his family
and so that's why I always would miss
him very dearly as they passed away I
mean the worst thing I think you can do
is retire retiring means that you maybe
have hated something that you did your
whole life and now you're retired
finally you get rid of this pain or this
horrible kind of like being an
assembly-line and some car factory
something again I don't know what it may
be but people just sometimes look
forward to retiring I mean I cannot
imagine why would I want to retire from
organizing the Arnold Classic I am
having a fall here I love coming here
every year you know I'm saying I cannot
imagine retiring from going to Gold's
Gym how can I retire from playing chess
with Franco how can I retire you know
going around and promoting a healthy
environment or the fitness crusade and
stuff like that or going to the you know
she was like incident to I can imagine
that there is such a thing as your time
and the men I think that the it will be
over when it's over define retires that
when you give up you know yeah I don't
know I mean some people just look
forward to that and like I said it
depends the ability of doors understand
one thing 74 percent of the American
people that is a poll that was done do
not enjoy the work
so this is why it is very tough it's
easy for us to say why would I retire
because I love everything I do but
there's a lot of people that don't like
their work and they're just doing it
because they need to make a living there
for family to feed and so they dig the
next best job but they don't really like
the job you know they done not and how
to switch over to another job and stuff
so it's very tough that's why I always
tell kids and my success seminars have a
clear vision where you want to go what
is it that you're really passionate
about and go after that no matter what
it takes
go after that as crazy as it may sound
because you got to do something that you
really enjoy doing that's right yes poor
fantastic direct response marketer which
you might own a business
okay so what dollar in the two concepts
well you know it would be all pay taxes
and we all hate the idea that you're
losing good money but there's a
difference between hating that you lose
their money in hating to pay taxes
I love paying taxes if it is the fee
amount and if it is used wisely I think
we all have to contribute that because
that's how you set up social programs
that are build infrastructure that's how
if a military of this kind of thing so
that's great but I always had to believe
that the money that I pay in taxes I
want to make up through a wise
investments so this is why I got into
real estate right away the seventies in
the started buying raw land and
developing that I started buying
apartment buildings and you know just
think about it I mean it would be in the
aramid in 1974 apartment first apartment
building and we bought it for two
hundred and fifteen thousand dollars but
it was then a lot of money yes and I was
only down like maybe thirty five thirty
seven thousand dollars but within two
years the apartment building was worth
in Sirte two
fifteen 350,000 dollars and assorted so
imagine now how much gain there was yes
I mean so we made hundreds of percent of
my initial investment well that's what
I'm talking about see it is it takes you
know thoughts and ideas can make much
more money than actual physical labor a
physical labor is always part of the
action because I always say you got to
work your ass up in the matter what you
do because now you have a great idea but
then you still have to implement it and
you have to has we have to go to the
bank at the financial statements at this
and that they raise money sometimes and
egos and look at the thousand apartment
buildings to find the right one and all
the sales things so you sort of the work
but it normally if it is just physical
labor you can never make the money then
you can make when you have ideas so this
is why it's important that was tell
people say the secret is is the certain
times don't think like when you get up
in the morning don't think just roll out
of bed so any life cycle or go on a
bicycle a right or go to the chain
broker do you know that's what you have
to do and then read something and learn
something so don't even think about it
but there's other times where you have
to really think and you really have to
get creative and have a clear vision of
variable to go and what you want to do
and that's what I always have that's
what I always believed and always
believed in making money so that then
you can do something with that you
invest in it notice eventually you
create the family if some of the kids
and all that stuff but also for charity
when I thought the dish was lega
instituted you will see yeah so we have
to raise money all the time that make
money do to do to pay for tetanus and
the support that 50 our 20th
environmental organization or any
organization any tea is great but if you
don't let the money you can implement
anything and so this is why it is
important that it is an environmental
organization or if it is my after-school
programs to the nationwide where we
raise millions of millions of dollars
every year or if it is just you know
living in it right the great
tension or driving a nice Bentley in the
Bugatti you know this is the kind of
things it takes money to do this kind of
stuff so therefore I believe in making
$1 in the two and having a good time way
to pay my taxes unless this is our I say
we have bad news you vo 15 million
dollars and taxes I say yes then this
releases what do you have you but I'll
inoculate that means you must have made
a lot of money yeah but make that much
money in taxes miss it yeah that's
waiting look at it is it's the way I
look at it but I tell you that I was
very fortunate that I had great heroes I
great heroes that they could look up to
and I mentioned two of them Mohammed Ali
and Sarge Shriver my father-in-law
but there's other great heroes like
Gorbachev Reagan Mandela great leaders
like Mother Teresa Chancellor Kohl and
Churchill and the list goes on and on I
mean those people had such an impact in
the world
single-handedly they've changed the
world we all can create change whether
it is now neighborhood or in our local
schools or in our country
it can't be big but it can also be as
little as just going to a school kid
that is problems reading and teaching
that kids are the read or how to do math
we don't have to just work on me
we should also work on we not just me
but also we remember that to lead a
truly full life you must give back you
must leave the world a better place than
you found it because the bottom line is
it is up to us I mean those rules that
have given you important rules but
giving back is one of the most important
rules you know in the Terminator you
have a very very famous line maybe your
most famous line ever but you explained
it when you were learning English you
didn't understand contractions you hated
them so you thought the line should be
said differently than it was written so
how would that line have sounded if
you've gotten your way I will be back
right I was as wrong as anyone can be I
was arguing with Jim Cameron Jim Cameron
wrote the script and to this mistake
number one you never tell a writer that
you want to change his lines and we had
to battle maybe shadows Cena said look I
just think it sounds funny when I say I
will be back I'll it's weird when I say
that and he said the mrs. McDonald let's
shoot it ten different whites let's not
get hung up should you say they're not
because you are going to say it because
I wrote it and I don't tell you how to
act and you didn't tell me how to write
so let's just move forward which is
suited 10 different ways you know it is
our gym and Elvis talk kind of
straightforward and if you shot at 10
different ways close-ups
medium shots long shots zooming shards
of everything you can think of and and
in a bit of time I did say it like 50
times with all the different takes and
shots it sounded right to me it sounded
strong to me because I just didn't feel
like it was strong enough and
machine-like enough and and on the hand
you know when I saw it in the film I was
happy that he convinced me to to save
that way and when you say a line like
that you never know if that the line
that becomes the most famous line in the
movie history and it just was voted as
number one line in movie history you
don't know that I didn't even know it
was any special at all
only when I promoted the film and I
remember was in New York and had people
coming up to me on the street and saying
the missus said
[Music]
and I said say what you say the line the
line from terminator is it which one
come on you know I'll be back line is it
okay I'll be back
no no just the way you stated in a movie
then I would say I'll be back
yeah yeah that's the one so I realized
then Jesus what did you create a monster
there or something like that it was like
why was like a big surprise to me that
it became such a big hit and he became
bigger as time went on and you know the
rest is history
thank you guys so much for watching I
made this video because Abhishek asked
me to also if you want to nominate
someone for the next top 10 video please
check the description for a link to a
video where you can vote for people and
put in your suggestions as well I'd love
to know what did you take from this
video what was the most important lesson
that you learned that blew your mind
that you're going to immediately apply
to your life or your business somehow
please leave it down in the comments
below I'm super curious to find out I
also want to give a quick shout out to
cam Jennings cam thank you so much for
picking up a copy of my book your one
word and the fun interview we did on
your youtube channel about it I really
appreciate this apartment and I'm glad
you enjoyed the read on the call we have
one Evan Carmichael owner and operator
of Ewa Carmichael comm and Evan
Carmichael YouTube channel now with over
six hundred thousand subscribers the
author of your one word - thank you guys
again for watching I believe in you I
hope you continue to believe in yourself
and whatever your one word is much love
I'll see you soon
body is very important but the mind is
more important than the body you have to
visualize what that body ought to look
like in order to make it win because
that's what creates in the will the will
that you need to go to the gym every day
the will that makes you go into the
fourth strips the will that makes you go
beyond and you do the five hundred pound
reps in the squats and you can't do
another rep and your body is shaking
it's the will that makes you go one more
time down and struggle up one more time
and since all of this or the mental
aspect that motivates you and it makes
the difference between you being in the
gym full of joy and looking forward to
doing that extra rep and looking forward
to doing this extra hundred reps in the
sit ups in Brooklyn past the pain
barriers that always the mind it's not
the body so this is why I think the body
is very important
but the mind is more important than the
body we have so many rules in life about
everything I said break the rules not
the law but break the rules my wife has
a t-shirt the wife has the t-shirt that
says well-behaved women rarely make
history or you know I don't want to
burst her bubble but the same is true
with man it is impossible to be a
maverick or true regional if you're too
well behaved and doesn't want to break
the rules you have to think outside the
box that's what I believe after all what
is the point of being on this earth if
all you want to do is be liked by
everyone in a voice trouble the only way
that ever got any place was the breaking
some of the rules after all I remember
that after was finished with my
bodybuilding career I wanted to get into
acting and want to be a star in films
you can imagine what the agent said when
I went to meet all those agents everyone
has the same line that it can't be done
the rules are different here just look
at your body here this huge monstrous
body and overly developed that doesn't
fit into the movies you don't understand
this was 20 years ago the Hercules
movies now there is the little guy
mr. vain Dustin Hoffman Woody Allen Jack
Nicholson before he gained weight of
course that is but anyway those are the
guys that Wayne and the agent also
complained about Max and he says no one
ever became a star with an accent like
that especially not with the German
accent in yes I can imagine with your
name Arnold Schwarzenegger or whatever
the name is on a billboard yeah that's
going to draw a lot of tickets until a
lot of tickets you're right so this is
the kind of negative attitude they have
but I didn't listen to those rules even
though they were very nice in this hit
look we can get you some good parts be
kingmaker get you to be a you know being
a wrestler or bouncer oh maybe with the
German accent we can get it to be a Nazi
officer in Hogan's Heroes or something
like that but you know I didn't listen
to all that this was their rules not my
rules I was convinced they could do it
that if I worked as hard as it didn't
bodybuilding 5 hours a day in a started
getting the work I started taking acting
classes took English classes took speech
classes dialogue classes accident
removal classes I even took I remember
running around a fine wine rose and a
bind
is it because Germans had difficulties
with the F in the W and the V to fine
wine grows and the vine I know what some
of you now say is the hope that Arnold
does its money back but let me tell you
something I had a good time doing those
things and it really helped me finally I
broke through I broke through and estava
getting the first part in TV streets of
San Francisco Lucille Ball hired me and
made pumping arms stay hungry and then I
got the big break in Conan the Barbarian
and there the director said if people
wouldn't have Schwarzenegger we would
have to build one now think about that
and then when ad Terminator I'll be back
became most is one of the most famous
lines in a movie history or because of
my crazy accent now think about it the
things that the agent said will be
totally a detriment and will be
impossible for me to get a job all too
sudden became an asset for me all of the
things my accent the body and everything
so it just shows you never listen that
you can't do something and you have to
work your way up of course run for
something else first I mean it was
insane in when I ran for governor the
same lines that if the rug give up it
can't be done and then of course I ran
for governor and the rest of course is
history they said you have to start with
a small job as mayor and then there's a
simply man and then you lieutenant
governor and then as governor and it
said that's the way it works in a
political career I said I'm not
interested in the political career I
want to be a public servant I want to
fix California's problems and bring
people together and bring the parties
together so like I said I decided to run
I didn't pay attention to the rules and
I made it and the rest is history as the
kind of movie star that you are were
certainly you can be addictive you could
say I want it and it gets done you can't
do that
you're absolutely correct and now this
is different but look this is the great
thing about it about the justing from
one career to the next and the key thing
always is is to keep your eye on the
ball well speaking of which it took a
lot of all to go cold turkey into
politics yes but you know I never had a
lack of that maybe find you it makes a
difference to move you could always say
what's the worst that can happen
did you fail I mean you know that just
says really not that bad